[Music]
so from Ohio the governor now planning
to restart reopen his state two weeks
from now governor Mike DeWine is with me
live and serve welcome back to our
program thank you for your time
don't you were one of the first
governor's outside the northeast or the
American West to shut things down what
are you seeing in your state today
governor you know we've flattened the
curve it's been steady for about eight
days or nine days now so we're happy
about that we'll be happier when it's
starts going down I mean while I look at
every morning as the hospital admissions
which is a lagging indicator certainly
but it's a it's a good indicator of
where we are so as I've told the people
of Ohio yesterday the monster is still
loose and it's going to be out there in
Ohio and across the country until we get
you know the shot that will take care of
it and will protect us so we've got to
continue to be very very careful people
who have compromised medical condition
have to be very very careful but what we
think we can do is you know there's been
businesses that have been allowed to
stay open because they were essential
and some of them most of them have done
a very very good job and being safe
they've got the distancing they've got
the hand-washing they've got staggered
lunches they've got all the things and
so we think they're other businesses out
there frankly that aren't really
essential technically but that would be
similar and we're going to just try to
start with them
and sort of open the state back up but
we're gonna be very very careful and
we're gonna take it one one step at a
time help us understand what we don't
want to do is have this go back on us
and then we have no things back so what
are the signposts that you will use to
tell you alright we're moving in this
direction and things at the moment are
a-okay well what are those indicators
well I'm not sure they're gonna be
a-okay because when you have people
dying in your state you know it's not
okay but I know what you mean
and you know we've now got that curve
flattened what we would hope to start
seeing is the hospital admissions start
going down and tracking in that
in that direction you know are
challenged today are one of our big
challenges is our hot spots and of
course those are any place where you
have congregate living we have big
flare-up in prison we have flare-ups in
different nursing homes and so that's
what's driving some of these numbers as
Ohioans have done a very very good job
in distancing but the people in those
situations that can't really distance or
can't distance very much and so that's
that continues to drive some of these
some of these numbers and tragically
some of the deaths coming out of these
nursing homes it's really it's it's
heart-wrenching I sell Michigan is
making a move toward May first as well
is there coordination regionally or I
mean look you took a step we don't your
stay down without coordination from
other states do you need cooperation
with others or can you do this step by
step on your own governor we're going to
do it you know it's going to be an Ohio
decision made by Ohioans but you can
always learn something by talking to
other governor's other people who are in
similar circumstances so you know
Kentucky Indiana Ohio we talk every week
you know we have joined with that kind
of a informal group we've done the same
thing with all the Great Lakes states
and that group even conclude includes
Kentucky as well so this is just an
opportunity for us to exchange ideas see
what everybody else is doing but you
know we're not gonna go lockstep I mean
I got a buck stops with me and making
the decisions and we'll do that in
consultation with Ohioans and the White
House and you know the governor's yeah
I've got 30 seconds left here this is a
big question for 30 seconds on the
screen for our viewers a number of job
losses in Ohio eight hundred and fifty
five thousand and four weeks
unemployment rate shooting sky-high now
at five and a half percent that has to
be a measure of your decision-making now
doesn't it it does and they're their
consequences their medical consequences
when unemployment shoots up like that a
lot of bad things happen and we can lose
a lot of people just because of because
of that downward economy so we know
we've got to do things we got to be
careful how we do it but we've got to
bring things up and so we can get get
moving again you're absolutely right
Thank You governor we'll check in next
week okay Mike DeWine and Columbus Ohio